I get the sense that don't blink was
your biggest risk yes don't blink was a
huge risk in the sense that it was my
first movie that I produced so I was
convincing people that I should do it
and that they should give me their money
and trust me with their money and go
finish a movie and give them a finished
product and I would not drop the ball
and I mean I didn't go to film school I
didn't have anybody give me a booklet I
couldn't like oh wait what's the answer
their problem oh it's right there is
that that's often thanks guys we do the
thing so it's over there I had no
idea and you know it's always
funny when you look back on your life
and you realize I was stupid you were
and I'm full of crap you were would you
like we can do it and so yeah it was a
huge risk for the investors and a huge
risk for me because I was not willing to
stop there I mean there was so many
times when there were issues and
frustrations and problems that you
wanted to be like oh my god I can't do
this anymore this is insane because on a
film budget like that I I paid myself
like 10 grand to produce and stuff
acting the thing and it took many years
to get this done so I know people who
wash dishes you make more money good
people good friends but yeah they're
they're making Bank compared to me I get
made fun of by Busboys is what I'm
saying so there's a point we like I
can't do this video I do like you just
exhausted but I realize I couldn't that
was the thing is I couldn't not do it
because then you never get another shot
no one will ever be like hey I heard you
up your first movie I'd love to
give you more cash No so the only chance
I get is to make this movie as best as I
can get
distribution dance like a monkey at Bar
Mitzvahs until enough people buy it and
my investors in the black then we
high-five and make another film but yeah
it was I guess if I really knew what I
was getting into back then I might have
back pedaled but that's kind of the joy
of being stupid wait I think he just
insulted myself do you think that's
stupid or do you think it's maybe having
that intuition that I got to do this
like to you know that it was mark Mara
and I watched him on something and he
said yes he's like I'm 47 he's like this
is like my life this is now yeah do you
think that you have a realization that
this is now and I need to make this
house yeah I have that more now I'm 45
and I feel there's a there's a great
poem by a dutch anonymous poet and it
says live as in quotation live death
whispers in my ear I am coming and I
don't mean that melodramatically but
banned all marches into the same you
know fairground so I feel like I'm
enjoying it more now I don't feel like
I'm desperate to try and prove something
I am proving it just by my life and by
my actions but I am very grateful that I
threw my hat over the fence to have you
ever the John F Kennedy story I haven't
John F Kennedy when he was a kid they
used to
he went to high-end fancy-schmancy
schools and they were uniforms and they
would have a hint
and they when they're coming home from
school they would walk by these gorgeous
estates and they'd be thinking what the
one who was in there over the fence we
should go check that out over there you
know like well we can't we'll get in
trouble and JFK would take his head
turned Rovers like well now I have to go
so I throw my hat if that make sense did
you have any sleepless nights oh yeah do
you yeah but two years yeah this is
don't blink is my baby yeah and I walked
around patting the film canister like
this and burping it and changing you so
the hard drive yeah when you got
stressed out was your way again till go
for a walk turn off the phone go and
then think it out and get some kind of
clarity or there was that when in
moments of conflict it was very
important to drink a lot of scotch no it
was important to yes be calm
breathe deeply watch other movies watch
other movies and if possible watch the
directors commentary and the producer
more importantly for me that produces
commentary because it helps you want to
put things in perspective even great
movies have problems you watch a movie
there's what a visit true romance great
movie love that film there's some
editing fuck-ups in there hard to find
him not gonna bring him up but there's
some definitely will that doesn't match
it's not a match cut edit his arm was up
here in one shot and I was down here in
this other side you like but that's okay
so it gives you that ability to stop
taking every nanosecond so personally
and you have
- you have to make Buddhist produce
aerial decisions that are for the
betterment of the film and for the
investor as well as for the audience and
can't be masturbatory and then there's
issue because you can't just be like it
has to be this way or nothing you have
to make a product that people want to
watch and the investor can get their
money back as opposed to never having it
end and being overly overwhelmed with
this one microcosm right here where you
have this whole universe to deal with
and trying to get a perspective on it
yeah it really is a life-changing
experience I'm sure I need everybody I'm
sure that your audience watches and
builds movies themselves and I'm sure
they know exactly what I'm talking about
you